avec moi geneviève guilbaud vice
première ministre ministre la sécurité
publique mena mme guilbeault bonsoir
bonsoir monsieur roy on va parler de ce
bracelet d'une nouvelle qui peut
de façon très pratique aider les femmes
qui se sentent menacés par des conjoints
violents ou des ex conjoints violents
mais d'abord un commentaire là ça
commence à faire pas mal de vidéos est
ce que vous vous dites je devrais
confiée à un autre corps que soient le
billet ou un autre une enquête complète
sur le service de police de la ville de
québec
mais pour l'instant j'ai vu les la
troisième vidéo mois en milieu
d'après-midi le entre deux rencontres
j'arrive de mon annonce sur les
bracelets anti-rapprochement
effectivement on est en communication
avec la ville de québec le service de
police pour avoir un peu plus
d'informations mais vous savez que j'ai
déjà confié il ya eu deux autres vidéos
le samedi et une hier sur deux autres
interventions dans la fin de semaine
dernière à québec la troisième on sait
pas exactement quand ça s'est déroulé
mais pour les deux premiers cités en fin
de semaine dernière à québec et j'ai
mandaté comme sarah la déontologie
policière pour faire des enquêtes en
plus des deux enquêtes qui ont été
demandés interne par le service de
police de la ville de québec et à cette
question es que le bio dit pourquoi pas
le bio il faut comprendre que le bo é
cij a confié une enquête au pays il y
aurait pour mandat d'enquêter
soulan d'infraction ou d'allégations
potentiellement criminel est ce qu'il ya
eu quelque chose de criminel si oui
est-ce que c'est assez pour que le dpcp
dépose des accusations contre un ou des
policiers ce serait seulement de dubayy
or c'est très circonscrit il peut y
avoir rien de criminel mais peut-être
des enjeux déontologiques et le rapport
du pays y serait confidentiel avec le
commissaire à la déontologie policière
on nous demande des enquêtes
indépendantes comme sarah déontologie et
très indépendant il a tous les pouvoirs
d'un commissaire lui aussi pourrait en
cours de route découvrir peut-être des
éléments potentiellement criminelles
auquel cas il pourra s'adresser au dpcp
où il pourra s'adresser un corps de
police pour une enquête criminelle plus
exhaustive mais il peut aussi lui abordé
langue déontologique est ce que le code
de déontologie a été respectée et
l'information qu'il nous transmettra je
m'engage à rendre tout ce que je peux
public donc d'un point de vue de
dépendance et de transparence et
denquête complète c'est beaucoup plus
intéressant demande at il comme ça
comment vous réagi ben là la troisième
vidéo je comprends que vous l'avez
regardé rapidement mais il ya quand même
dans cette troisième là il ya des choses
troublantes quand le policier qui
s'adresse façon extrêmement agressive à
l'homme en question le pouce sur la
voiture
c'est troublant n'est ce pas
oui mais ça s'ajoute en plus aux deux
autres le cyclo ya une séquence de trois
on a pas quand le contexte puis je
voyais un extrait du du maire de québec
qui dit il puis moi je le dis depuis
quelques jours l'on sait pas ce qui est
arrivé avant s'est pas ce qui est arrivé
après on a seulement la patrie
fragmentaire de ce qui est sûr les
vidéos d'où l'importance d'avoir des
enquêtes puis d'avoir des informations
plus complètes or là la saison 4 l'un
est terne et surtout cette
information-là savoir d'où à quel moment
s'est déroulée cette intervention qui
sont ces policiers les tout ça le
service de police de la ville de québec
devrait être en mesure non maman d'avoir
cette information lors de communiquer
ces lieux entourant cette affaire le
faucon faut pas aussi perdre de vue le
fait que d'un service de police
municipale l'employeur de ces policiers
le seul service de police la direction
c'est la ville de québec donc c'est à
eux aussi à prendre en charge toute la
question des bonnes pratiques la gestion
des ressources humaines et tout ça moi
je peux pas me substituer aux directeurs
de police de la ville de québec donc je
laisse par ses communications mais moi
j'ai pris ma responsabilité de ministre
de la sécurité publique armand
d'attendre comme sarah la déontologie
qui pourront nous faire rapport et si eu
des manquements déontologiques il ya une
instance qui s'appelle le comité de la
déontologie policière devant lesquels
peuvent comparaître les policiers avoir
des sanctions s'il ya lieu s'il ya lieu
en vert on va regarder son veau suivra
évidemment bon le bracelet vous avez dit
en conférence de presse on n'a pas le
luxe d'attendre
on n'a pas le pass aurait pu prendre
mille ans avant qu'on développe ce genre
de technologie là ça n'existe pas tant
que ça sur la planète il ya 1,5 pays je
crois sauf erreur qui en ont c'est un
bracelet faut expliquer aux gens
électronique oui mais c'est pas pour
garder quelqu'un à la maison c'est pour
empêcher que quelqu'un se rendre chez
son ex-conjointe par exemple oui et
c'est différent du bracelet électronique
le bracelet électronique quand on le met
sur un contrevenant par exemple un
terroriste qu'on veut surveiller en
permanence l'on parle d'eux ce lait
anti-rapprochement donc il ya deux
partis à ce dispositif là il ya une
partie qu'on installe sur l'auteur de
violences conjugales qui garde en
permanence qui peut pas enlever 24 donc
on peut le suivre en permanence à
distance et une autre partie qui c'est
la victime qui le l'autre partie d'une
espèce de bouafles de cellules ans
qu'elle peut traîner avec elle et donc
ça permet qui est toujours un lien une
traçabilité entre une géolocalisation
réciproque si on veut le entre les deux
parties donc si le contrevenant
s'approche dans une zone qui lui est
interdite trop près de la victime mieux
une alerte il ya une alerte qui est de
nos policiers les policiers peuvent tout
de suite se rendre pour sécuriser la
victime s'assurer que le contrevenant
peut pas l'approcher et dans un deuxième
temps localiser le contrevenant question
parce qu'il y est un bris de condition
on manque c'est très concret et puis
c'est très technique puis c'est très
prometteur et surtout surtout ça peut
ramener la paix d'esprit la paix
d'esprit aux femmes qui sont prises dans
l'enfant de la violence conjugale ses
auteurs notent violence leur dérobent
lalala leur enlève la paix d'esprit
l'autonomie le pouvoir sur leur propre
vie donc on espoirs avec ceux de leur
redonner cette autonomie loupé cette
capacité de vivre un temps soit peu
normalement on pense à qui très
précisément des gens qui ont été faut-il
avoir été condamné pour violence
conjugale où on peut être en attente de
procès et la loi peut nous obliger
quelqu'un à le porter les deux sont
possibles à l' enquête sur remise en
liberté donc au tout début d'un
processus judiciaire quand un homme est
accusé de par exemple de voies de fait
ou d'une offense en violence conjugale
il comparaît devant le juge et le juge
doit décider s'il va être remis en
liberté en attendant la suite du procès
ou s'il va être détenus c'est décide de
le remettre en liberté il va pouvoir
imposer le 10 bracelets donc à ce moment
là la victime à cette sécurité d'esprit
dont je vous parlais parce que s'il est
remis en liberté sans le bracelet
actuellement les femmes disent mais il
n'y a pas le droit de m'approcher j'ai
toujours par qui viennent chez moi quand
même c'est pas condamné donc il est en
attente de procès n'est pas condamné
habituellement on lui donne un ordre de
ne pas s'approcher d'eux de la femme
mais souvent ils respectent pas cet
ordre là donc on veut faire en sorte
qu'il respecte cet ordre la
wii est d'amener cette paix d'esprit là
dont je vous parlais mais ça c'est sûr
que ce sera la discrétion des juges les
jeux je veux avoir le pouvoir d'imposer
un bracelet ce seront eux qui décideront
les jeux c'est le pouvoir judiciaire
s'est complètement l'écart le
gouvernement et tout ça donc je veux pas
me substituer nullement à l'éventuelle
décision d'un juge mais ça va être
possible aussi de l'imposer pour
l'éventuel fin de sentence un jour les
gens qui sortent de prison et les femmes
sont stressés aussi donc le jeu je
pourrai dire à la salle afin de la
sentence à la fin de la peine de
détention il va porter le bracelet par
exemple pour 18 mois 24 mois on pense
que combien d'hommes vont porter ça
c'est difficile à évaluer pour le moment
on a un bassin potentiel
approximatif d'environ 2300 hommes qui
sont condamnés pour des infractions de
nature de violence conjugale
annuellement à se font enlever toutes
sortes de personnes qui pour diverses
raisons par exemple problèmes de santé
mentale refus de la victime parce que ça
ça peut être pour être installée
uniquement avec le consentement de la
victime comprend vis la victime veut pas
traîner sa peine géolocalisons pourra
pas le faire mais donc en enlevant
dessous nous on n'envisage pour
l'instant 500 bracelets à terme 6 2 un
long vol un plan tombe le premier
bracelet on sera le gouvernement qui a
installé le premier bracelet sur une
première femme je m'attends ce qu'on le
fait pour verrouiller au mars belle
famille en or maintenant je croisais là
mais une première femme qui pourrait
rejoindre steria la paix d'esprit début
2022 et fin 2023 ça sera implanté
partout au québec on n'envisage pour
l'instant 500 bracelets évidemment au
fur et à mesure on va voir ça en prend
plus y en aura plus pour l'instant c'est
2 2 un peu le rodage l'apprivoisement
puis on l'espère le succès de cette
mesure là c'est un rodage mais est ce
que c'est un projet pilote est ce que
vous pourriez dire on n'aime pas ça
marche pas aussi sûr qu'on y va
en ce moment c'est ce qu'on y va c'est
sûr qu'on y va on implante
progressivement le bracelet au québec
sur 2 1 on est en décembre 2000 21
décembre 2000 23 ça va être disponible
partout on commence après projet ici
dans la ville de québec parce que les
conditions gagnantes sont réussis ce que
je sais c'est que les premières fois
c'est sûr que ça va être une nouvelle
expérience on va falloir que les gens
s'habituent on va embaucher des
ressources que tout le monde s'est
habitué à travailler ensemble mais mais
oui moi je vois très bien qu'on conserve
sa l'élu centre qui aide les femmes en
détresse ont applaudi la mesure on dit
que et
comme je vous disais on peut souligner
que ça a été fait quand même rapidement
parce qu'on en parle depuis un certain
nombre d'années là mais là vous vous
êtes dit de 20 le nombre de féminicide
launay je répète ce que j'ai au tout
début nous étions n'a pas lieu à tanger
et à chercher de l'argent puis ça y est
le rival
exactement j'ai déjà annoncé 223
millions au mois d'avril pour une série
de mesures maison d'hébergement organise
qu'elle les hommes policiers procureurs
et j'avais annoncé en décembre dernier
qu'on faisait l'étude de faisabilité
d'implantation du bracelet fallait quand
même voir qu'est ce qui se faisait
ailleurs les six pays qui l'ont en ce
moment et comment est-ce qu'on pourrait
les planter ici j'ai reçu mon rapport
final le 31 octobre et on est le 1er
décembre et on annonce qu'on les plantes
progressivement on va commencer dans
dans deux trois mois donc oui ça aurait
dû prendre plus de temps normalement
mais j'ai fait en sorte que ça se fasse
rapidement parce que 18 féminicide c'est
à ses fonctions peut on empêcher ne
serait ce qu'un seul avec ce bracelet
puis surtout cette paix d'esprit je vous
dise a pas de prix quand on parle aux
femmes là c'est l'enfer ce qu'elles
vivent donc si ça peut apporter la paix
d'esprit et limiter les futures actions
violentes et je pense que ça valait le
travail geneviève du beau merci de nous
avoir parlé au revoir merci à vous pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit
oh